yoth monde sait ça suffit les conneries
qu'on soit au top pour la suite doubt
l'aston vais aller couper le gaz me
dites pas que l'homme à l'assiette et
des retours
par pitié aaa au au data semaine ne te
cache pas comme le maïs est sûre supplie
je n'aime pas trop ça où allons nous le
couloir de l'ordre de l'horreur on va
passer par cette porte
bouazzi baroche mont garin j'ai essayé
de faire toutes les salles pour pour
reculer plus possible le moment où tu
dois aller dans ce [ __ ] de couloir ah
[ __ ] l'eau au petit face et à la simon
gars j'en étais sûr j'étais sûr
cache-toi cache-toi cash pour la mairie
ne voit pas sur le matin seulement de
faire une sieste avec lui des cachets
sympa le plan je trouverai un autre
chemin
va t'en dis moi qui est ma droite merci
fait quoi il va aux kouriles speedy tout
seul va chier ça marche
allez y va à droite bas à droite
c'est quoi ce bug
allez arrête ton show vous gaver dans la
salle d'à côté ah oui c'est gros plan
avatar mais non mais pourquoi d'un coup
non non la porte
non je ferme ils sont 2 ferme la porte
voilà comme ça on est bien en tête à
tête avec lui c'était foutu de a à z
allez on y va on a beaucoup de courage
j'ai envie d'aller dans le coin là en
fait à [ __ ] ne bouge pas coucou dans
la peur le r&b arrête de vouloir des
tête à tête avec lui
regards et les surexcités c'est pas
possible et je m'enfuis ça suffit ok pas
comme ça par la wii ont mis mon gars il
faut le tenter c'est bon il est parti il
faut ouvrir cette porte défoncée pour le
bien de l'humanité
pourquoi pourrait qu est-ce qui va il
m'a vue pourraient musique s'enclenche
m'en fous je trouvais le chemin j'ai
trouvé la voie j'ai souri va manger du
sanglier
il m'a enfermée quoi ah d'accord qui on
passe d'une salle de bains une autre
salle de bain au oui oh oh [ __ ] mais
juste la taille de l'ombre quoi je filme
actuellement cet endroit plutôt glauque
moi ça fout le camp c'est ma place je
veux pas de prendre ta place
1 déjà dans un premier temps la mienne
elle juste là c'est beaucoup plus gaza à
sauvegarde des cas surviennent en bas à
gauche tu sens que tu es pas bien t'es
pas bien psychologiquement la moindre
aide à elecam onu maintenant en fait
avant il avait un petit slip un petit
truc qui veulent acheter tout propre
maison mais doumecq mais non mais ça
allait on part pour un marathon comment
ça se passe et partie marathon casier
c'est bon batta j'ai vu non
c'est un cul-de-sac on fait quoi on fait
quoi on fait quoi 1 2 3 soleil 1,3 sur
l'étape à d'autres scènes laisse moi
laisse moi laisse moi laisse-moi
m'énerve je sais plus quoi faire avec
lui il ya pas moyen de m'éduquer quoi
cet homme mais c'est une blague mais
pourquoi des trous dans ses casiers tac
je te claque la porte au nez
question à faire ah oui bah c est plutôt
intelligent non on esquive aie honte
skis pas vas-y j'ai la foi y aller là
faut trouver un moment aussi à salut
bonjour
ces prix pour le facteur là il se passe
dans l'instant il m'a pas vu aaa
j'ai lu ce travail en sprintant d où ce
genre de geste fort au nom mais arrête
est terminée je regarde ça marche non
mais qu'est ce tu fais pas le moment de
jouer mais il ya un mais quatre ans pour
un tout nu avec une seat il suit lui il
ya une partie fait attendre puisqu'il ya
peut-être un jeu c'est la roue oui au
oui non peut attraper par les jambes
ben oui mais arrête aussi non mais
respecte toujours pas les règles bon bah
les styles sont au dessus et on lui a
mis mes gars cher pas pourquoi il vient
jamais je retiens qui viennent qu'on
fasse alors
alors comment je coupe ce [ __ ] de gaz
c'est ça allait à la radio dans la
prison ah ouais du coup faut que je
retourne à un [ __ ] ta gueule c'est la
yes bien biche c'est bon ok on est bon
il ya tout vient d'en bas à gauche
est-ce que tu aurais vu une pile non non
c'est pas ça que je cherche ah bah non
c'est bon mais on est là on était au pic
à aller par là bim bim parfait
sauvegarde
alors ça mais nous pousse toi toi qu'on
va avoir des problèmes on est dehors mon
gars mais dites pas qu'il est dehors ce
mec là il va attraper froid après mec je
vois rien je vois rien alors j'estime
cette vue c'est la mort instantanée quoi
on parle à hiesse non au oui il est
fâché binger massachusetts chaises et
attendre
j'attends non prison' blog [ __ ] c'est
la honte puisque je dois aller où
dois-je aller au la déception déception
terrible attente jeu avec une tête on
s'en va c'est tôt mais glauque et un
bruit au bâton mais je viens te suivre
jusque là pour qu'il se passe rien ah ok
fallait juste que j'avais en face d'une
part faut sauter quoi yes je voulais me
faire peur c'est complètement raté mon
gars ouais tu ne t'es pas toi moi je
suis de l'autre côté patois allait me
semble que ce qu'on le crâne un peu de
votre coup ils sont pas gentils après
c'est parti à l'annoncé bon tu te calmes
rabat joie non au aux mecs et tu te
détends derek quoi foule quand tu vas y
laisser ta nana c'est bon j'ai foutu le
camp en mer aux eaux les bâtards la noix
de coco le grand retour je suis dégouté
je m'en vais pas pour longtemps
ah oui d'accord ah non mais attends à
nourrir une accord ce crâne mais mais
mais complètement peu humain coups bas
où je peux m'en allais pas où je peux
m'en aller [ __ ] aide moi à guide moi à
oui par là vous n'aurez jamais aucun fan
tutte partie bactéries confie-t-il est
malin il s'est dopé mais c'est sûr c'est
sûr qu'elle me tuera calme-toi calme toi
on va juste procédé à un contrôle
antidopage je vais vous calmer monsieur
monsieur monsieur ouais ouais d'accord
ouais ouais je m'en bats les steaks
ouais d'accord nous y voilà
alors qu'est ce qui se passe là on peut
voir des gens qui s'amusent à faire du
des ombres chinoises
oh merde oui tu leur fais ça
oui oui la radio what you want ou non on
était à ça on était à ça au nom aux noms
ont été un poil ah non non non mais mec
mais là c'est trop souvent notre
contrôle il fait partie de makoko fait
pas plaisir de trouver ici parc ela la
radio la radio avait sauvé qu'à la base
il répare des ordis peut bien réparé un
petit truc comme ça
non non quand faut y aller faut y aller
d'accord donc ça c'était le plus gros
feu de la planète terre toute entière
alors allons-y hi hop ça c'est la fuite
j'aimerais quart des femmes ça fait deux
années et demie clef actuellement je
parle de cette ville dont je suis pas
trop serein l'homme team poursuit
factuellement 4 169 kg par la yes la
porte s'ouvre
mais pas trop un fait est dû à tout
jamais dans la forêt allez on s'en sort
c'est la vie qui nous attend aidez moi
aidez moi j'ai besoin d aide
j'arrive bon apparemment tu es décédé
désolé on va passer par là assurent une
vilaine des charges attend à quelqu'un
remis le haut
c'est là bim yes yes et maintenant non
c'est quoi c'est bien un truc dans l'eau
mais ça n'en finit jamais oh mais c'est
quoi cette manière alors tombe pas du
ciel comme ça à mon gars non make it à
éduquer quoi habits sont pas éduqués
sauvegarde et tu monte monte monte cet
escalier qui te plaît assez bon faut
faire un saut eux c'est bon et qu'elle
non non tu vas tu lâches pas tu lâches
pas tu lâches pas tu lâches pas terminé
mais ça me sort par les temps plein ce
mec il est pas doué e j'ai pas les
hôpitaux et là on va tomber au milieu
des mains d'un psychopathe mais dans
quelle merde et ce qu il est encore
tombé
bonjour ah oui les a pas d'accord
j'avais pas vu mais vraiment pour le
coup ils ont l'air vraiment silence au
si vous êtes rapide nous livrons à lui
dois m'en bas l'homme très méchant et
1re senior bon je m'en vais steak
allez à bientôt mon voyage mais on part
sur 1,12 à des radeaux les murs tuer les
rats non et on tourne en rond depuis dix
minutes l'agent peu plus loin à marla
c'est bon on est bon on est bon on est
bon on est dans l'endroit le plus
glauque de la planète terre mordelles
genre d'endroit où il dissèque le
marsupilami ici quoi oh tu vois plus je
te vois je te vois plus je te vois je te
vois plus je te vois ce qu'on ait caché
là dedans au phoque à [ __ ] faut
changer les piles change au courant j'ai
pas le choix je sais pas où je vais ces
labyrinthes
non mais tout le monde et psychopathe
dans ce jeu sauvegarde chéri avatar il
arrive vite trop de pression la aaa
berceau des chaînes je l'avais vu à elle
pouvait tomber s'écraser que non mais
c'est pas possible
mais non mais arrête deux mais il fait
que tomber mais j'en ai ma fille tu
m'aurais plutôt plutôt que d'être avec
moi je t'apporte franchement nous oui
et hop et rien comment je boite comme
une bonne grosse merde quoi tomber dans
le jeu en place
cette fois je vais leur hockey dont il
faut que je passe par là je peux me
cacher ici
faut que je me cache ici je pense on va
bien voir ado ya un trou de ou fait
valoir direct au wat mais dont il prend
carrément le quasi tu te dressant un
cadeau pour moi une friandise à déballer
à déballer encore bien savourer mais non
mais non mais non mes bébés qui prend le
casier carrément quoi ah mais ça a mal
fini à 6 thouars latin ils incarnent
tour sûrement fram a amené la bayanne si
moins de 120 années aux quelque chose à
sauver faucon lettres au collège lève
toi mon gars a même jeté tout du
bâtiment et des tons pop
ah non mais va nous rattraper mais
regardez regardez moi je le canard
boiteux coup nous sommes là savaient pas
qu'on retrouvait dans un casier quand
même ça ce débat une fois pas deux fois
non plus pas ton anniversaire non plus
yes on s'échappe et la liberté
bon ça marche je pilote cet épisode on a
eu une jambe complète pour casser cet
homme est tombé deux fois alors qu'il
était à 7 sont sûrs mais peu tapé
trompette règles pense à cette scène là
où truc en bois ces deux cas c'est qu'on
est tombé sur del à la petite larme à
l'oeil qua non mais c'est pas du tout
mais j'ai pas de larmes c'est bon
j'espère que ce deuxième épisode vous
aura plu je pense qu'on est presque à la
fin du jeu et on le terminera quand même
dans un troisième épisode qui à tout le
monde
[Musique]
c'est
et